I'm gonna be the best night to Kingdom  oh [ __ ]  ten years of training has led to this  how am I supposed to be at night for  these people this is a cesspool nothing  separates the men from the boys like  combat why do we have to strip for this  like I said men from the boys now line  up according to bolt Patrick and we  can't put every prisoner to death  exactly an execution is a sometimes  trick like ice cream and BUTT STUFF  right wait you're a witch I'm not  [Music]  what's in here hi welcome to the Queen  sex dungeon aka the fun dungeon what the  that might be the worst thing I've ever  seen that's worse  the kingdom is super fun  princess I'm here to save you kill like  what are you obsessed with me  stalkers it's my job to polish you when  turns into diamonds I know how to  field-dress a man and use him as a  sleeping bag skin that's cozy as hail  thank you  [Music]